[Music]
so this lecture has four recent games
that were played in the last month so
I'm sure you're familiar with them and
one of my favorite endings to a game
from a few years ago and then an even
better ending from even years further
past now this is the game between st.
Louis resident Georg Meyer who's played
at our club many times versus vitomir
Kramnik who's better than Meier way life
goes in this position it's black to move
and you will notice that white is
threading an interference tactic okay
well though I may not notice because you
haven't met the rating requirement for
the class but if you did you would
notice white is threatening Knight f6
check and the Queen is no longer
defending f7 and then white would play
Queen f7 and probably win maybe draw but
probably win and unlike most people
Kramnik see stuff and then does
something about it okay and Kramnik
played nine to d5 which defends f6 but
doesn't really stop the threat of Knight
f6 and then Queen takes f7 so Meier
played nine f6 and if you play Knight
takes Knight I will play Queen takes f7
if you play pawn takes Knight I will
play Queen takes f7 if you play King h8
I will probably play Queen takes that
might play Knight takes Knight I have to
think about that
so black play the only move I didn't
mention Queen takes f6 which was the
idea of 9 to d5 now the idea is not to
sacrifice your queen for 2 or 3 pieces
the idea is to checkmate why it because
checkmates good you can't take the Queen
because Knight f4 check would be
checkmate as ken west will explain yeah
he says yeah after Knight f4 Jack
White's King goes the first rank and
black plays rook b1 was made
now Myer didn't want to get mated so he
didn't play pawn takes Queen but that
was a very nice defense from Kramnik
now if white plays Bishop takes tonight
black will play Queen takes g5 check and
then black is up to pawns and it's
threatening mate on b1 and the bishop is
hanging so Meyer didn't do that
so if Meyer didn't play Bishop takes
Knight and Meyer didn't play pawn takes
Queen which allows me what did he do he
played Queen takes Knight okay and now
it looks like the game should be a draw
because if white plays pawn takes Queen
if black plays pawn takes Queen white
plays pawn takes Queen it's opposite
colored bishops and the bishop on f3 is
threatening d5 and white rook is on the
seventh and that makes up for his pawn -
and now kramnik made the only winning
move and actually when I first looked at
the game
I thought Queen a4 was winning because
Queen f4 threatens everything it
threatens the rook on c7 and it
threatens the Queen on d5 and if the
Queen on g5 moves let's say to d7 then
the g5 point is hanging with Chuck
however after Queen f4 white is black is
not winning who can figure out why Queen
to f4 what's the only move for White
Queen f4 white only has one move that
draws and actually the theme of the
lecture this lecture is to find the only
moves because in most chess positions
many moves will do like in the starting
position even though one of my chest cam
students thinks Knight f3 is the worst
move it's still good I move one efore is
still good d4 is still good etc etc so
in most positions many moves are okay
but in a lot of positions only one move
will suffice some say the world was in
fire some would say ice and ice is nice
and will suffice
right ken west see ya
that's correct after Queen f-for white
plays rook to C for attacking the Queen
and the computer says black only has a
slight advantage kramnik found a much
better move which wins the game very
nice move and he saved his queen but
kept pressure on the g5 line
yes somebody was gonna say something
Queen a one very suspicious
well that moves the Queen but that
doesn't put any pressure on white why
could just move his Queen C now this
point is weak because it can't be
defended by other pawns
it's barely defended now and if you take
it it's check so you want to keep in
this vicinity of that pawn queen of g6
now white as a problem pawn takes Queen
is a winning threat and if the Queen
moves away from the g5 pond then Queen
takes g5 check will win so white asked
to move is Queen and keep it on the g5
pawn the problem is
black will then play rook to b5 and
scoop it up and then black will be
winning and that's what happened we work
to b5 and he threw in this move and the
reason is he's trying to get white to
either made himself or hang his queen
but he didn't do that and in this
position white resigned
since White's down to pawns for nothing
however an interesting variation if he
didn't resign would have been Queen
takes a six now he's knocked down two
pawns and if he could have safely played
Queen takes a six he would not have
resigned but since he could not he
resigned so who sees the win here for
white for black do they win for white
let me know if I don't see it you see
the win for black I do see that one
black to play and win one of my 1800
players
very good there's my 800 player Queen at
five King g2 is forced I'm sure you
expected that h3 now if the King goes to
the back rank Queen b1 check is good for
black so King goes to g3 and now no
sacrificing this isn't the advanced
advanced class this is the advanced
class Queen g5 and maid
now since why can't do this he would
just be two pawns down with a bad
position so he gave up as an advanced
class you could understand that okay you
did tease them more I don't teach you
guys enough okay
the next game is between your two
favorite players at cmbottrell and
richard rapport now that's a micro is a
famous prodigy from what country yes
France yeah when he was 13 he played a
match with Smith Slav I believe and I
think he won so this slot was not 13
borrowed promised a lot but in recent
years his rating has been same so he's
been 2700 feet a for 10 years now 2750
not 2788 just 2700 terrible he's been
one of the top three players in France
for 10 years but he's not top 10 in the
world he's out top 20 in the world he
just sort of hangs around you know top
top three or four in France now richard
rapport 17 years old
2,700 that's pretty good okay he's the
same age or younger than Ray Robson and
60 points higher rated so he's pretty
good and he's playing in his first Super
GM tournament and he didn't win any
games ah
so that was unfortunate okay now we have
this boring position wait oh this is
most exciting position ever
okay this was played last week in the
Biel tournament Biel being in your
favorite country Switzerland also it's
BL bien once French had ones
germán I assume must be German I was in
BO in 1993 before you were born
I was talking to Julia and that was a
nice tournament now in this position
Bhakra played nine takes b6 and if
you're paying attention you'll notice
that white has four past poems that's a
lot okay and white has two rooks for
three pieces
assuming we recapture now troops for
three pieces is about the same some
would say three pieces are better some
would say cheer oaks are better but what
is better is four passed pawns now
that's better
okay so black has to be careful because
four passed pawns that's serious now in
this position black has one move that
draws but he didn't find it so he lost
ah now in many games including your own
usually it's not that one side plays
well at one site plays badly in the side
that plays well wins usually you both
play badly you guys know what I'm
talking about and then one of you
decides to make the worst move at all
time and minus 100 okay at the top level
it's very similar top level they both
play okay you know not bad and then one
guy makes the worst we've ever loses and
that's what happened here this position
it should be a draw if black plays the
only good move he didn't do that then he
was completely losing I hate when that
happens
okay so what is the only move that draws
not to understand the position you'd
have to remember white has four passed
pawns so if both sides play normally
then White's gonna have four passed
pawns
so then black will lose so black has to
play abnormally now what is the one
problem with white in this position what
looks a little out of sorts
what's that King is exposed and he
hasn't castled that's correct
if this King wasn't exposed and he had
castles this would be a very easy win
because as I said earlier unless I
forgot to say it for passport yes
Queen now five is closed the reason
Queen f5 doesn't work is quite humorous
okay uh orthopedic surgeon told me that
joke one person left what's that why
well wait we're not we're not done with
his Queen f5 yet okay if Queen f5 white
makes his King safe by castle and Queen
side okay and then then his king is safe
when the fact castling queenside is the
only winning move Queen not five his
claws been suggested before Queen takes
d4 is is not for this class so Demetri
has to leave that's for the beginner
class tomorrow which I'm also teaching
if Queen takes d4 trip to d1 and
beginner class then you lose your queen
and then I three past parties it's not
clear what's better for pass laws or an
extra queen and three past queen g4 is
the only drawing move now don't feel bad
the guy also didn't find it queen g4
threatening Queen g3 check and perpetual
check and it's funny every possible
normal move year for white is all zeroes
every move is a draw because blacks
could have be down a hundred pieces
amazed give a perpetual check anyway
black blundered by playing a takes b6
now White has two winning moves and they
have the same idea but the one D plane
is much more beautiful now in this
position black would like to play Bishop
takes rock which you guys see very good
congratulations and Black has it even
better move which you don't see if it
was black to play what's the best move
for black the best highly recommended
cha Bishop d5 trapping the Queen on g8
he when that happens in my opinion
although I didn't ask him black simply
did not see White's next move black
probably thought I'm threatening the
rook I'm threatening Queen to g4 like I
was last move and I'm threatening
to d5 so I'll just take back on v6 and I
have a good game but why it's completely
winning and this is a line clearance and
Dimitri helped us out thank you when
black played queen takes d4 in Dimitri's
analysis white played rugby one winning
the game the reason white was winning is
his deep one wasn't on d4 there was no
deep one
if white had no deep one here rigsy one
is quite interesting
therefore white played d5 I don't think
black saw that that's my opinion and now
it's over computer says plus a billion
and the reason it's over well obviously
Queen takes losses to rugby one which we
just discussed if you don't take it
which he did not then you're in for pass
pawn remember that okay so if you do
take it Bishop takes d5 that's the only
possible refutation I think you play
queen g4 so we'll get to that and why
does what why why did white do this what
was he thinking
Julian the only one who could possibly
know he's like I resign Queen takes d5
right to d1 and I hate to say it but
three passed pawns okay and then you
take and I Jake and whites winning cuz
White has three passed pawns also the
Bishop on g7 is not very good okay and
that's that's the best black can do but
no Grandmaster would have black there
cuz three passport okay and I think he
just didn't see d5 by the way if you're
a computer then e six also wins here
that's much more complicated okay but d5
now because you asked and whap or knew
you would ask
he played queen g4 now Queens you for in
the previous position when before d5 the
Queen and Bishop were working out so
black could play Queen f3 as well as
Queen g3 but now you can't play Queen f3
so King f2 and that's the end of your
counter play
and then he didn't resign he just kept
playing until I quite had four queens so
the rest of the game was sort of silly
from a super GM perspective he played
for Czech that's pretty good he checked
him okay
yeah they played Bishop c8 yeah and I
mean they're playing chess but for past
pawn countries' is yeah
now if if you take it and rook f4 and so
forth so four passed pawns right and now
he resigned but it's cute actually
if king a7 White has a very nice force
checkmate which will impress you because
most of you haven't met the rating
requirement for this class so you'll be
very impressed Julian will not be
impressed so be like you know ridiculous
Queen a8 check very good King takes most
of my students and can't play that
because I don't see king takes but they
say mate and black says yeah you're
right
and then you Queen without taking the
night and then you play rook e7 and now
most of you see what's going on
yeah then you play Queen a it again yeah
second time works out even better yeah
so repor resigned after Queen d5 check
because for pass point yeah okay so that
didn't work out well for black basically
because of one bad move if you'd play
Queen g4 I wouldn't have shown you this
game but he played tank so I could show
you and then all the stuff that he
missed and that's why you've never heard
of him
see if he had plays other moves you
would it's at all that guy I know him
okay now you guys think rear obstinate
because you know you're living Saint
Louis what do you know and this is very
common in my life is people think what
they know is good and in chess you think
Ray Robinson is good because that's the
best you've seen and unfortunately
ray Robson and the US team were in China
two weeks ago and because the USCF is
about or being taped here the u.s. CFR
wonderful
it was an answer the US versus China and
the UN they asked the USDF how much
money they had for the match that was
their answer okay so the match was
sponsored for the USD by the Marshall
chess club very suspicious okay so did
Nakamura play No did Cosby play no did
Irina crush play no didn't as a Tomsky
play now so we sent our next best
players oh and the final score they
scored over a hundred points and we
scored a little slightly less than 50
I'm not kidding
that was the final score they went by
over fifty points now ray Robson was
bored too I believe unless he was bored
one he might have been bored one yeah
one as [ __ ] didn't play and Graham
didn't play either might have been bored
one anyway it was a shave winning
ravening and style where's uh what's his
name the other Ben Conover yeah where is
he
yeah he's Dutch it's a Dutch resort it's
from slave in England because I was
there and they told me but you say she
Vanagon now she Vanagon is not only an
opening but it's a style of play it's
your team against their team but instead
of board one playing board one and board
- playing board so you actually play
everybody everybody in every team Paz
early for the other team
that's the Siobhan Egan system so Ray
Robson played all the Chinese and they
played twice they played like in 15
minute and in two hours and all that
nonsense and if you thought that Ben got
crushed you see other women did and
because without sat on skiing crush that
we got crushed okay with the C now this
is the game Ray Robson is black and the
Chinese play you've never heard of his
wife they have the same rating and this
position is a draw assuming both sides
play correctly now ray Robson has one
very big weakness and if you want to
betray Robson this is your best hope
okay and that is to get him in a time
trouble and hope that he makes an error
in time trouble like all of us do and he
gets in a time trouble every single game
so that makes it easier okay and of
course he's in time trouble and he plays
after a for the terrible move h5 one of
the worst lose on the board and if white
plays east six it's a draw because after
East 6th nobody can do anything black
plays e6 that doesn't do anything can
play King f8 to have something nobody
could move if the King moves towards the
rock you're giving all your pawns away
if the rook moves black pushes his pawn
so basically after East six they just
move around doing nothing and it's a
draw and computer agrees saying it's all
zeros but Ray Robinson played h5
horrible move now if your opponent wants
to play e6 and that equalizes you should
probably stop that so he played six
now there are five legal moves on the
board right ken west and Ray Robson
played the fifth best not good by far
the fits best very good when I want a
bad move I know who to call on when here
it was the worst legal movie setup King
f6 the worst legal move wrote to g3 I
hate when that happens
threatening rook g6 made so he went for
a completely equal position to resigning
in two moves that's the best America hit
now okay well that's what happens when
you get in a time trouble and that's why
you should avoid getting into you know
no time at all on your hawk yeah so yeah
e of six would be a draw but he played
h5 notice how black checkmated himself
rook g6 wouldn't be made if that Paul
was on h7 he had to work hard playing h5
then king of six okay I figured it out
if only he was here in the audience and
I would tease it more okay but he's not
here and he resigned ok terrible now
unfortunately my next game is a Ray
Robson game which he also lost he was
playing the best and/or second-best
player in China which is Wang Huy you
could have also said Wang Hao those are
the two best players two years ago it
was clearly Wang Nui now I don't know
probably one how probably and Wang he we
scored
some insane score like nine out of ten
against the American players he's like
no Nakamura in Kamsky oh boy
he was like yeah that's what I'm talking
about they're gonna play every year this
match the next one's gonna be in New
York next year so hopefully we could get
the top US player okay in this position
white played Bishop takes c3 this
position has an equal amount of material
Ray Robson's black and blacks Knicks we
was totally insane so I assumed he was
in time trouble I hope now black has
only one problem
black has a great pawn structure pieces
good open files square but the bishop on
h5 is a little iffy if if white plays g4
you might lose a bishop that's happened
so I show this to one of my students who
was rated like negative a million and he
said I'd play g5 years my bishop can get
back that's not bad
computer says knight c6 is a good road
and some other move was okay rook
somewhere double something Ray Robson
played a very suspicious move and
there's a reason why it's suspicious so
if he played the move he should say to
himself if this move is bad this is why
that he could refute that analysis and
conclude their moves not as a move is
fine however the reason the move is bad
is good reason and it just wins and I
don't know what he was thinking I'm
getting it he played rook takes e4
losing immediately now when he played
rook takes e4 since he's Ray Robson
better than me he would assume that
that's very dangerous so he would
probably look at Queen b3 which is what
was played now the thing is White's
gonna play Bishop f1 and rook to c1 and
that rook spinned
so ray Robson defended his rook and
unpinned it sort of with Queen a for now
I'm threatening to take the Queen and
the rooks not pinned and blacks apart up
so I assume when Ray played rook takes
e4 this was his intention and he did
so what's wrong with this position how
does what's the winning move for white
excuse me who g4 and then you lose your
bishop well that that then that would
lose your Jeep on because there's a rook
defending it now there's not a rook
defending it
yeah so I'm wondering like I wish I'll
see him at some point we'll play tennis
I don't know and I'll say what why did
you do that because I don't know why he
did that because white made the most
obvious through than the most obvious
move then he has to resign so I don't
know like it wasn't like white made this
he move a high he like attacked a bishop
that's trapped me pinned the rook so
rook takes c4 is very dangerous because
it's on the same diagonal as the king so
you got to be careful when you make
moves like that
usually if worked a c4 was a good move
that's a computer move because the
computer sees that g4 doesn't work a
human is really afraid of g4 and Queen
b3 because you're getting pinned and
attacked so Ray Robson gave all his
pieces away and then he didn't have any
pieces it's too bad
okay and he resigned cuz he's down a
piece ah so I'm gonna ask him like why
you did that okay and again it wasn't
like Wang Yi we played a hundred moves
in a row and Robson played a hundred bad
news they just had an equal position
they robbed some plated insane move and
resigned which is what he did the
previous game and I see that a lot the
games ended in one move the game is
about equal and then all of a sudden
it's like that and I have games like
that also we're on the losing side
usually again Shabanov he's my whatever
the word is well you're you you were
right er yeah there you go
I was thinking doppelganger Brown his
doppelganger I don't know but anyway I
was thinking of a good word not you know
so anyway I played Chihuahua for 25
years and I have no wins I have some
draws and when I do
usually it's equal and I make like
negative 50 move and resign that's I
lose just like this and if you got
chests like this one anybody got it yet
I got mine yesterday yeah my game was a
block from the championship is there
where I make the negative 27 move its
guy didn't lose in six hours I lost in
two hours I didn't have to suffer okay
and Shabanov in three days is playing in
the World Cup cuz he won that game if
you had drawn or lost and I'd be there
losing in the first round now he gets to
lose in the first round there's seven
Americans playing in the World Cup which
starts in three or four days in Norway
128 player knockout how many of the
others eight Conrad Holtz playing Shabbo
of khai dinh of Robson shaking my head
means the girl lose in the first round
however we have three players who might
win not come whereas a big favorite con
she's a big favorite and ownership is a
small favorite the other ones it's they
fly to Siberia then fly home it is in
Siberia my kiddin you know Conti
Muncie's your favorite place now
the guys you speak Russia or like what
was that mean Conti Mon Sisk
anyway I never want to chest there for
some reason people like when it's cold
yeah okay so now we'll skip over a
Robson a little bit because we can't
stand all this losing now we'll look at
one of my favorite games now many of you
have a favorite player named Alexander
Costa and York as Ken West probably is
nodding in his head if not in real life
and if you go to the third floor you'll
see her picture in your mind and I must
admit she want my favourite players
because I like playing her cuz I take
all her pieces and made her so I like
that okay
look Austin York is one of the top
female players in Russia and where does
she live in Miami in Florida it's on the
top Russian players and she just played
in the European Women's Championship and
did quite a while I think she tied for
third or fourth pretty good there were
many many grandmasters and I am so not a
bad score and this is a game she played
a long time ago how long ago thanks for
asking
it was so long ago that she was playing
Sergey Karjakin
they have the same rating now that's a
long time ago because car Hawkins right
now is 29 million and urges the same so
her rating is twenty four fifty which is
what it is now and he's twenty five
forty but he's twenty seven eighty now
so okay well he's still higher rated now
this isn't walk
this isn't like all it's good think re
Aachen had that move that's not what
this is this is he saw a million moves
ahead and she didn't see one move ahead
and you you see less than that okay I've
never been so mad at all of you and you
would home him even madder so in this
position costume your create an error
and then she continued to do so as was
the style at the time and this is a
typical error for a weak player okay you
could tell her I said that okay
weak players they don't like when
there's tension they got to get rid of
all that they don't want to calculate a
hunt this like okay we'll just take
everything and see what happens so
that's what she did she needs to chill
out and like make a good move make like
a solid move improve her position but
now she played Bishop takes d5 now karak
I knew that ten years later I would give
a lecture on this position and he wanted
to impress you guys
and he played a move so amazing that
it's almost as amazing as the last move
of the game although it's not we see the
last move of the game you'll be frozen
in your chairs forever never to leave
and then the kids will be like who are
these people on Sunday and the move is
drumroll Queen takes a six just what Ken
West would have played now when you play
Queen takes a six it's important to see
the final position it is if you don't
then Queen takes a six as a blunder but
of course you saw and though he moves
ahead
that's why his rating went up several
hundred points after this okay now the
best move for black once again is a safe
solid improving move one that you would
not consider that's why you're in this
class the best move is rook on C to b8
that's the best and after that move
White has a big advance
possibly not winning but maybe but it's
like 0.7 so it's on the cusp okay
instead Kosta Nick thought she had him
hi he fell for my trick and she played
the winning continuation but not winning
for her okay she played rook take c1
check and she figured that he would take
and she was right and she figured she
would take and she did and she figured
he would play this is the easy one rook
c8 check now most of you are analyzing
Queen f8 Bishop takes d5 check and white
wins so she played Queen okay and this
was her plan when she played rook see
one now if I can digress when you
calculate variations where the
variations are tanks tanks tanks tanks
takes you have to be right 100% of the
time not usually
because usually means you're gonna play
like steinitz I make two blunders a game
and you'll make five good moves and two
blunders means you're down seven so
that's not good okay and when costume
your calculated this you obviously
missed the last move obviously now here
my computer says Bishop takes d5 check
is equal then King f8 rook takes Queen
King takes and my computer goes on and
on you're totally baffled cuz I can see
your bafflement but the chip takes d5
check is equal because my computer says
so anyway she probably knows Bishop
takes d5 check and maybe she correctly
concluded it was equal maybe not I don't
know but sorry I complained take c8
which is the correct move which I'm sure
cost two o'clock and I'm sure kraken saw
and she played it's a very good and now
black is drawing or better accept that
White has one move that makes black
resign and that's the oh she didn't see
that's the move cockin saw when he
played Queen takes pawn surprising all
of you now he's going to surprise you
more
ruk to eight I hate when that happens
well unless I'm white then I really like
it
and that's the difference and we see
games like this that morphe played if
you were here for the intermediate
lecture which some of you were this is
typical morphe stuff he sees stuff as
opponent didn't so he wins and usually
if I'm showing you a car yakin game he's
playing Kramnik and you know it's a draw
okay but now I'm showing you where he's
playing a lesser GM who's not top ten in
the world and you're like oh yeah I
didn't see that darn I give up then I
have to give up I hate when that happens
I'm leaving sure that text is called
like trash-talking tactic Rick hate oh
okay I mean I wish I could play Rick a
ever played was like that and obviously
he saw truck hate when he played Queen
takes a six otherwise you can't you
can't do this
plenty this many so here when he took he
saw take-take-take chat gear here here
here like for sure he saw it a thousand
percent and when he played this game he
was twenty five forty he wasn't 2770 so
I hate to play twenty five 40s who see
that because I don't see anything
take everything okay but yeah
unfortunately
and so his rating went way way way up
and hers didn't so yeah if you want to
get a good at chess you study tactics
like that for ten hours a day then you
play it once in a while they hey that
guy's good okay so even this kind of
tactic he may have seen before maybe
okay my last game is between Bronstein
and Korchnoi
now this game I did not know and my son
told me about it and then I went to the
Internet's today and I looked up
Bronstein I was like Bronstein is no
good he's like Bronstein's the greatest
player ever so we looked it up and they
have one game in his Wikipedia article
and it's this one so he didn't know that
my son's that's sort of funny so I've
run into this game a lot lately okay and
this game was played before everybody
was born including the players and this
was play to nineteen
t-too and a match between leningrad and
moscow and julien's like excuse me
what's leningrad okay so Korchnoi one of
the world's leading players played a
horrible blunder here because it was
1962 what do you want yeah okay and they
didn't you didn't do 4,000 tactical
problems a day then I'll tell you that
and he played the obvious smooth that
you all want to play with black very
obvious requir who what's the obvious
tactical move that Court should I played
Queen f3 and the best move would have
been King to g6 but who's gonna find
that and now white supply and wind this
is why bronzed is almost the world
champion and you were not you were
almost not able to get into the lecture
that's the difference
white supply and win very nice tactic
and again it meets with our theme of the
lecture the only move it's not like
course no II played bad every move and
Braunstein played well every move course
they made one bad move and Bronstein
found the only way to stop it in my
opinion which you could disagree with
but I'm right even before Queen f3
Bronstein saw that Queen f3 was a losing
move he had he had all figured out and
yeah question I played anyway time
trouble didn't see it out yeah and I
gotta tell you a funny story was its
pasti I think it was spa ski small ski
was asked why you know why why isn't
course nerd a world champion his close a
few times
and spa ski said horse should i is a
great openings player he has a great
imagination he understands end games
been a buddy I've ever met he plays the
French defense and the open knew he was
black better than anyone he tries hard
and one I've ever seen play chess he
studies all the time and he does
everything
and they're like well then why is he
world champion
because he has no talent so Queen takes
f3 Rakesh a check was played Korchnoi
played it's too hard for this class
King g6 and now white played the only
winning move winning the black queen
queen where Queen eh Queen e1 that
that's illegal in hangs beaten one
oh man say in chess camp the two kids
were playing one of them was okay the
other one was not okay and and I'm
standing there and I'm like I'm trying
not to look cuz and the kid says what
did he say he said you can't take your
own piece and you're in check that was
what he said to his opponent he was
right the kid took his own piece and he
was in check anyway
so his illegal for more than one reason
but what he said that I was like wait I
gotta see this wait you can't take your
own B's and you're in check
alright what's the move anyone Bueller
aren't you guys as good as Bronstein I'd
beat Bronstein come on it's true - I am
we won't talk about the games he beat me
Shh the answer isn't queening a question
mark am i right the answer is the right
answer with variations to back it up
Queen d6 rook takes Queen solid that's
the over eighty hundred class for you
I can't believe Bronstein is better than
you guys he's not even alive Bronstein's
greatest contribution the chest in my
opinion which nobody agrees with is he
dreamed of a great game he had a dream
he woke up and he showed the game and it
was like White's act all his pieces of
the King's gambit and one was a great he
made it up but he would dreamed it
there's a really good game too that was
his greatest chess contribution also
he's almost the world champion but that
anyone who Queen b6 with no idea
so Queen f6 then draw greed maybe blacks
better
yeah blacks better yeah blacks better
may be black would win these two pawns
hanging White's King is open Queen h4
mate the correct answer is the obvious
where it takes age sex and black
resigned of course of course okay so
there's two obvious moves pawn takes
rook and King takes rook okay if King
takes truck then we check the King goes
to the G file then we check and if the
King goes to f4 we play Queen f5 and
Queen takes Queen the King goes to F
sick we play g5 check and Queen takes
Queen so that doesn't work and the other
move is pawn takes rook and then we play
Queen g8 check Queen f8 check and Queen
takes Queen so it work takes resigns I
hate when that happens
well actually when I'm white I like it
yeah that's pretty good
terrible now of course a computer would
play rook h6 without saying like just
easy work that I
this on Houdini after Queen f3 at like
enough trillionth of a second sly Creek
a j-rock age six plus eight like nothing
but for humans that's tough and that's
why certain people Hikaru Nakamura are
pretty good because man when he saw that
fast that's that's his specialty he'd be
playing Rakesh a trick a jig so quick
he'd be saying he'd walk in the door now
and he would be like I reckon HEA
wreckage legs and walk out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]